lorsque je suis rentré à maurice il y a
un peu plus de trois ans après quelques
années passées à l'étranger
on m'a dit que les mauriciens et et
casanier on m'a dit que vous n'aimiez
pas sortir on m'a dit que l'art et la
culture
les gens n'étaient pas fan et puis ceci
est arrivé
go
pour louis by light c'est l'oeuvre de
tous c'est l'oeuvre de tous les
mauriciens de tous les artistes de nous
tous port-louis by light c'est la
rencontre entre la créativité et les
gens port louis
la première édition en 2015
le festival a été à transformer port
louis en un espace de 40 mille mètres
carrés une scène géante ont pour on
pouvait croiser toutes sortes de
disciplines artistiques où on pouvait se
balader la nuit à port louis et
découvrir des sites historiques mis en
lumière
c'était une d'une grande émotion
j'en ai encore aujourd'hui je pense que
port louis
cet événement à réveiller en chacun de
nous en chacun des festivaliers une
sensibilité et un éveil à aa au
patrimoine et au potentiel du patrimoine
à maurice alors que nous nous attendions
à voir cent mille personnes en trois
jours
port-louis by light à stimuler le pays a
été au delà de nos attentes nous avons
reçu 450 mille personnes en trois jours
vous imaginez vous nous avons reçu des
témoignages des centaines et des
centaines du monde entier et de maurice
mann des messages qui arrivait sur nos
réseaux sociaux des lettres des milliers
de messages exprimant beaucoup d'émotion
de gratitude d'encouragements aussi
et d'espoir on a pu voir que la diaspora
s'est reconnecté avec fierté
avec maurice et nous tous on s'est senti
fier d'être mauricien le festival à
connecter les gens de manière culturelle
artistique sociale mais aussi émotionnel
aujourd'hui on se demande encore comment
est-ce que tant de gens sont venus ils
sont revenus
pensez vous que c'était parce que
c'était gratuit
certes la gratuité était un facteur
intéressant
c'était comme un cadeau offert à tous à
l'occasion du début de cette saison
festive début décembre
mais au-delà de tout ça nous avons une
étude par shia urnes at de l'université
de maurice qui nous a révélé que les
gens étaient venus par curiosité il
avait le souhait de découvrir port-louis
la nuit mais aussi ils sont venus pour
s'offrir un moment de loisirs en famille
mais au-delà de tout ça cette sensation
magique que nous avons pu ressentir en
se baladant dans la capitale
cette sensation d'être connecté à la
ville aux gens pour louis by light a agi
comme un catalyseur entre les gens et la
ville entre les gens et port louis et
comme l'art et la culture est un
catalyseur pour rassembler les gens
pour louis by light c'était une
magnifique aventure d'une synergie de
plusieurs métiers des techniciens des
artistes des communicants des ingénieurs
des architectes et bien d'autres encore
au début nous étions 2 et puis nous
étions 20 et fille nous étions 50
et puis 500 et fit 1500 et puis 450
milles ça a été un rassemblement est
dans cet esprit fédérateur 1 au plus
grand défi était de réunir le
gouvernement et le secteur privé
quelque part c'était un projet pilote
c'était la première fois et il a fallu
réunir leurs visions mais également leur
volonté est aujourd'hui en leçons de cet
événement ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
la collaboration est une des clés du
succès notamment dans le domaine des
industries culturelles et créatives
la culture c'est ce qui nous fait vibrer
la culture c'est ce qui nous nourrit
c'est ce qui nous éduque c'est ce qui
nous fait voir les choses d'un autre
angle
imaginez-vous le pays sans culture sans
danse sans musique sans couleurs
lorsqu'un h lorsqu'un artiste s'exprime
il cristallise un moment de vie un état
d'être un état de la société lorsqu'une
ville s'exprime elle rayonne
l'expression c'est l'essence de nous
mêmes en plus lorsqu'un homme s'exprime
lorsqu'un homme je pense qu'un homme
peut être bon et un homme peut exprimer
le meilleur de lui même lorsqu'il est
confronté à la beauté et à la créativité
dans ces moments-là on ville présent
lorsque lorsqu'on se balade et la nuit à
port louis et convoyait renaître le
théâtre sous les feux du vidéo mapping
où on voyait des artistes de talent ou
encore lorsqu on imaginait le voyage de
nos ancêtres
lorsqu'on regardait le ballet des
pirogues sur le port ou encore lorsqu'on
se balader et qu'on regardait des
artistes musiciens jouer à tous les
coins de rue on vivait le présent c'est
ça la beauté de l'art et l'art génère la
créativité et l'art génère du bonheur et
la créativité
j'ai la créativité génère de
l'innovation et dans les villes on a
besoin d'innovation
le festival port-louis établit des
normes et des expériences amenant une
stimulation et une énergie pour les
jeunes
construisons quelque chose de nouveau
pour demain quelque chose d'excitant
pour nous
cette initiative a réellement le souhait
de revitaliser laura culturel de port
louis
nous avons de la chance d'avoir une
capitale si historique est si belle et
lorsqu'on pense à port louis
dans dix ans nous avons envie d'une
ville meilleur d'une ville avec des
espaces de rencontres avec des espaces
publics une ville avec de la créativité
avec de la synergie une ville pour les
jeunes pour nous déverrouillez
port-louis s'est déverrouillé maurice en
prenant soin de notre capital c'est
toute notre île qui va en bénéficier
et on ne peut pas nier aujourd'hui que
nous ne sommes pas prêts les mauriciens
sont venus ils se sont engagés ils sont
prêts on a besoin de stimulation
on a besoin de créativité on a besoin de
loisirs à maurice et les industries
culturelles et créatives ont une grande
affluence
ça apporte un feel-good facteur à tout
le pays
ça crée des emplois et les industries
culturelles et créatives ont énormément
de potentiel aussi au niveau du tourisme
ça génère aussi du trafic touristique
saviez vous que 20 % des américains
voyagent en fonction d'une raison
culturelle un musée qu'ils souhaitent
visiter ou encore un festival qu'il
souhaite voir
et saviez-vous que les industries
culturelles et créatives représente
aujourd'hui un secteur de plus en plus
important 2200 milliards de dollars dans
le monde soit un chiffre d'affaires qui
est le double du secteur du tourisme en
france la culture représente cette fois
plus que le pib
avec port-louis by light on l'a vu des
emplois ont été créés des métiers des
gens aux puces spécialisées
on a pu améliorer nos compétences une
industrie est en marche
c'est l'industrie des arts et la culture
et pour les sceptiques sachez que
l'événement de port louis a ramené à la
ville à l'économie 171 millions de
roupies soit cinq fois plus que ce qui a
été investi au départ et pour la
majorité d'entre nous je pense que le
simple fait de se sentir mauricien est
de 7 centimes mauricien c'est juste
inestimable
aujourd'hui les mentalités changent
évoluent nous pouvons faire le
changement c'est la beauté de l'humain
alors je vous propose de l'influencé
notre futur merci